>> Marisa Bellack: Hello.
I'm Marisa Bellack.
I'm an editor at "The Washington
Post," a charter sponsor
of the Library of Congress
National Book Festival.
I'm pleased to introduce Ellen
Hopkins, bestselling author
of 14 young adult novels
and four adult novels.
Ellen fields a lot of
questions about how
to become a successful
fiction writer but her path
to success wasn't
necessarily typical.
Although she published her first
poem in a newspaper at age 9,
in 1964, she didn't start
writing for a living
until her mid 30s and she
didn't publish her first novel
until age 49, in 2004.
Along the way, she ran
a catering service,
owned a video store,
showed horses,
freelanced for newspapers
and magazines,
and wrote 20 nonfiction
books for children.
You may have noticed
that gritty novels
about difficult subjects
have become a thing
in the world of young
adult books.
But they were relatively
uncommon when Ellen got going
and that's not what
she set out to write.
As you may well know, her
first explosive novel,
"Crank" was loosely based
on her daughter's
experience with crystal meth.
Ellen chose to tell the story
from a fictional
daughter's perspective
to better understand her
real daughter's decisions
and to examine the role
she played as a mother.
She began the novel in
prose but switched to verse
because she has said
in interviews,
"Poetry is so interior.
It was the right way of getting
into Kristina/Bree's skin.
Since then, Ellen has written
on topics ranging from abuse
to suicide to AIDS
to teen pregnancy.
Her newest book "People Kill
People," officially out Tuesday
and we think there may be
some copies here today,
delves into school
violence, white supremacy
and other timely issues.
I imagine she'll say
more about that today.
Before we dive into our
discussion, I'm supposed
to mention that the Library
of Congress has been
the Festival host
since it began 18 years ago.
I want to thank festival
Co-Chairman David Rubenstein
and the many sponsors who
made this event possible.
You can support the
festival with a donation.
There's information
in your program.
Please note, too, that there
will be time for questions
after Ellen's remarks and anyone
who asks a question
will be filmed
for the Library's archives.
And for those who are
interested, Ellen is scheduled
for a book signing session from
4:00 to 5:00 this afternoon.
Now please help me
welcome Ellen Hopkins.
[ Applause ]
>> Ellen Hopkins: And please
help me thank the not fake news.
[ Applause ]
Okay, how many of you
guys follow me online?
Really? You guys are
scared of me, aren't you?
I don't blame you because
I am a political beast.
So I first of all before I
talk about me or my books,
I really want to tell you how
grateful I am to be in DC today.
This, you know, this place,
like I live in Nevada.
I live in Northern Nevada,
not Las Vegas, okay.
There's a whole different --
And yes, it snows in Nevada.
So when you're back there, you
know, we tend to look at DC
as like this monstrosity.
It's so, at least now, I
mean our political space is
so contentious and it's like and
-- I think we need to really,
really find ways to come back
together as much as we can.
I hope our books will
start to do that again.
But I was in the hotel
room this morning
when Mr. McCain's funeral was on
and I couldn't tear myself
away from it, you know.
It was like to watch people from
both sides of the aisle be able
to come into this space
and to honor a man
who was able to do that.
For me, I really feel honored
to be here today to have shared
in that space somehow.
I don't know, I know that's
kind of weird and kind
of a weird thing to talk about
but I really wanted to say that.
And so I do write
-- I write books.
You know, there's
this new article
in "The Wall Street Journal,"
you guys seen it,
The darkness of YA.
Well, you know, being a teen is
like not the easiest
thing to be.
You know, I mean seriously.
My childhood, my teenage
years, they weren't that easy
but teens today, the things
they're experiencing are harder.
I didn't worry about guns
coming into my school.
That was not a concern
at all, you know.
Now we're teaching
elementary kids how to zigzag
down the hallways, you
know, and it's like, okay,
we need to change things.
And I think books are a way
to be able to bring people
to open eyes to problems
that our kids are
experiencing every single day.
So I hope the parents out
there will read my books
with their young people and
open up lines of dialogue
and discussion because
that's how we are going
to change things and make
things better for our kids.
And don't be afraid of books.
Books are a safe, safe
space to explore addiction,
to explore abuse, to
explore gun violence,
which is what I'm here with,
"People Kill People,"
brand new book.
I wanted to explore gun
violence because it's something
that our kids are
experiencing every day,
a fear of this in their lives.
And so we need to figure
out why this is happening,
who it's happening to and
who the perpetrators are
so that we can hopefully
turn this around.
I'm going to read a little
bit for you and I'm going
to read my author note
because I want you
to know why I chose to do this.
This is the author's note.
I grew up with guns.
My dad who was both a hunter
and an avid collector taught
me to respect firearms.
I am, in fact, an excellent
shot and at another time
in my life enjoyed
target shooting.
I could even do black
powder rifles.
Have you ever tried those?
They're like weird.
Today, however, I
don't own a gun
and as an animal
lover would only hunt
if it was that or go hungry.
I respect the Second Amendment
but we must address the
gun violence problem
in the United States.
Statistics show a steep
rise in gun-related deaths
and injuries since 2014.
In 2017, as of November 6th,
more than 13,000 people had died
as a result of non-suicide
gun violence
with an average 93 Americans
killed by guns every day.
The yearend total would be
around 18,000 non-suicide gun
deaths, up 4000 from 2016.
Suicides generally account
for 62% of gun-related deaths,
which would put the total
figure at more than 47,000.
Mass shootings, three or
more deaths per incident,
also show a precipitous
upward trend.
Young people are
often involved both
as victims and perpetrators.
While the outcome of
stricter gun control continues
to be debated, I felt
it was important to try
and understand why
someone might be compelled
to pull the trigger.
This is what authors do.
We ask why.
Why are people prone
to violence?
Why do people seek revenge?
Why do people hate
or fear or despair?
Why do people kill people?
If we can understand the whys,
perhaps we can begin
to solve the problem.
The characters you'll meet
in these pages have powerful
life situations driving them
in negative directions, any
one of them in a precise moment
in time might decide to
pick up the gun and fire it.
If they seem familiar,
it's because they are,
at least in some small way,
inspired by stories that pop
up in news feeds every day.
They are fictional but real.
My editor made me put
a disclaimer in there.
Views do reflect my own.
I would hope that
you would know that.
So on my dad, my dad
was an amazing man.
He was the hardest
working person I ever met
and he was a weekend alcoholic.
By that I mean he
never touched a drop
from church Sunday
until Friday night.
Friday night until church
Sunday, he was wiped out.
So he was a responsible
gun owner.
He kept his guns locked up.
I only saw them come
out on a few occasions
when he went hunting or on two
occasions when he was drunk.
He put a loaded pistol
to my mom's head.
He didn't pull the trigger.
She was able to talk him down
but that was something
I witnessed as a child.
So all it takes is the wrong
time, you know, the wrong second
for something to go all wrong.
I'm going to read a
little bit for you.
So all 13 of my YA before
this one were written in verse
and they were all first person.
Every book I've written up until
this one I wrote first person.
This book, the narrator
is omniscient
and the narrator is the
voice of violence as seducer.
The six characters you'll meet
in the book are all
written in second person.
So I invite you onto
the page, you,
to become those six characters.
I was going to do the
whole thing omniscient
and then I kept wanting
to address the reader.
I kept wanting to talk to
you as these characters.
And so I said -- First, I had to
rewrite the first 10,000 words
in second person but I wanted
to address you and to invite you
to become these people so
you could into their heads
and into their spaces and
become these characters,
which I want it to be an
uncomfortable experience
for you.
So I don't think you're going to
be comfortable reading this book
and that's not what
it's here for.
But we'll start in
the voice of violence.
You, yeah you, come
here, please.
I need to ask you something.
Have you ever felt the
desire to hurt someone,
I mean pummel them, wound
them, watch them bleed?
Did you? Would you?
Could you?
If I were the gambling type,
I'd put my money on yes.
See, there's this thing
inside every one of you,
the collective human
call toward violence.
All it takes is one singular
moment to encourage it into play
and the lamb transforms,
becomes the lion.
Take it one step further.
Have you ever thought about
killing someone, I mean,
poisoning them, bludgeoning
them,
grabbing a well-honed knife
and carving them to pieces?
Chances are you haven't,
wouldn't,
couldn't follow through,
contemplate.
What's required to become
the catalyst for death?
A moral compass sprung
and spinning haywire,
antifreeze flowing
through your veins,
or perhaps nothing
more than circumstance?
In that instant when the
lamb unleashes its roar,
would you heed the
call or instead defer
to the quivering
voice of reason?
Like dawn and dusk, existence
and demise are inextricably
linked as per the grand scheme,
either drafted by some
all-powerful architect
or randomly designed.
Perhaps this is the
true knowledge of Eden,
not the mechanics of procreation
but the promise that once time
on Earth is nothing more
than a journey toward
inevitable departure.
Surely the ancient ones who bore
witness to birth in the wilds
and death from claw or club or
predation by creatures too small
for the eye to identify,
we're aware of nature's plot.
As their spines uncurled
and they drew upright
to run discovered the value
of flint, the power of spear
and arrow, the lust
for blood billowed
like a black-bellied cloud.
Oh, to wield a weapon
mercilessly extinguish a
beating heart.
The millennia crept forward,
dawn to dusk to dawn to dusk
and humankind shed its
fur, fashioned clothes,
deserted its caves in
favor of villages, cities.
But even as people learned to
plant, harness sunlight and rain
to nurture garden fields, their
passion for the hunt remained.
They killed in the name of
survival, protection, vengeance.
They killed in response to
lust, jealousy, despair.
They killed for the
thrill, the simple pleasure
of witnessing bloodshed.
Think for one delicious moment
how they would've watched
in wide-eyed reverence the
advent of gunpowder marvel
at the fire [inaudible]-,
its relentless evolution
from crude spear-driven flame
thrower into a fierce weapon,
able to discharge 1000
flesh-ripping metal projectiles
in 60 lethal seconds.
Ponder their amazement at
a machine with the ability
to level entire villages, infant
to ancient in mere minutes.
They would've fallen
on their knees
and lifted their
arms in worship.
Now you understand the
talent of a firearm
but perhaps you're
unaware of the force
to feeling its seductiveness.
You know how sometimes
you hear a whisper fall
over your shoulder but then you
turn to search for the source,
find nothing but
landscape behind you?
So then you tell yourself
it was just a case
of hyperactive imagination,
convince yourself
that sentiments don't
materialize out of thin air
but the truth, at least
as I like to tell it,
is that the voices
who speak to you
from inside your head have taken
up permanent residence there.
Some shout warning
prodding you to take cover,
flee or brandish a weapon.
Others murmur haunting you
with poetry, like mine.
So the voice of violence
is in verse.
The six characters are in prose.
I'm trying to grow
my readers up.
So if you guys go back to
my first books, you know --
How many of you guys started
with me with like "Crank"
or "Burned" back then?
So you guys know as I've moved
along, like those earlier books,
there's more white space
on the page, right.
And I've kind of -- And there's
less stylistic verse on the page
and that's because I'm
wanting to grow my readers up.
So the early books were like
very simple to read, I think,
although the verse for
very linear readers,
like for older readers, it's
hard to get to the verse
as storytelling because we're
taught to read like this.
Young people, their
brains pick up knowledge
in a different way now
because of computers
and the way computers come on
and the way they use
their phones and stuff.
So their brains are actually
hardwired a little differently.
They're actually a little
more open to the idea of kind
of alternative formatting
visual interest on the page.
So it's been a pleasure for me
to be able to bring nonreaders
and reluctant readers to
books through that kind
of more visual interest.
But then I also want
them to become readers.
So if you go all
the way through,
the verse becomes denser and
then you're going to start
to get some prose from me.
Like the book I'm writing
now, it's almost all prose.
Yes, I am writing a new book.
The 2019 book, which, okay,
let's talk about that
just for a minute.
So this book is a change for me
and the book I'm writing now,
which the name might change.
Right now it's called
"Sanctuary Highway."
It's set in near future,
near future as in like day
after tomorrow, if this
country keeps moving
in the direction it's
trying to move in.
So it's a very political
beast underneath it but it's
about a group of kids who
end up together having to try
to escape the country
into Canada, basically.
And I hope my kids
never have to do that
and I hope your kids
and I hope we don't ever
have to try to save our kids
from being rounded
up and locked up.
So that's what I'm doing now.
What else is going
on in my life?
Well, let's see.
So if you follow me at all,
you guys have been
around with Kristina.
You know that she's got --
The real Kristina is my daughter
Krystal [assumed spelling].
She now has had seven children.
Only one lives with her.
So we adopted the first.
So Hunter, the baby in the
back of "Crank," he's now 21
and he's the least ambitious kid
you have ever met in your life.
I'm like, "Are you ever
going to have a real job?"
He's like, "I'm thinking
about living in my car."
I'm like, "Really?
Not in my driveway."
Yeah, okay, have fun with that.
No, he's actually, he's
a musician, so he's going
on the circuit, the
festival circuit.
I'm like, yeah, okay, good.
Then there are two others.
So the two -- So if you read
"Fallout," right, that book was
from his point of
view, Hunter, right.
And then two other girls, they
live with their paternal aunts,
one in Phoenix, one in
way Southern California.
Five years ago, my daughter
had a major relapse,
like where I had to go down and
pull her kids out of a very bad,
bad, bad, ugly situation.
So we took guardianship
of the kids.
They were then three,
four, and nine.
We still have them and they
are now eight, nine, and 14.
One just started high school.
Yes! I was hoping to have
another kid in high school!
At least it keeps me close
to my readers, right.
So there's that and then
she had a baby in jail
after I took the kids
and so he's with her now.
She's actually doing
pretty well now.
She's had a job for a while.
He's three.
So she's had the same job
for a couple years and she's,
as far as I know,
doing pretty well.
But she also married the abuser
that was abusing these children
and so they will
not go back to her.
They don't want to
go back to her but --
So that's kind of where she is
but that also kind
of changed my life.
You know, it's like, I
was like going full bore
and then it was like,
put the brakes on.
Let's stay for a while
and take care of kids,
get behind on writing
projects, piss off my publisher.
What else happened with that?
So that slowed me down a
little bit but now I'm kind
of like back into like
this whole kind of needing
to move forward and
to keep going
until I write some cool books.
I'm not supposed
to talk about it
but there might be
a movie coming.
I haven't signed
the contracts yet,
so I'm not actually
supposed to share that.
It's "Crank."
[ Applause ]
And for those of you who
are worried about it,
I get total script approval.
I get cast approval.
I get to like make sure that
movie is what it needs to be.
So I'm excited about that.
That's coming up.
And that's moving into
kind of a new space, too.
So that's kind of fun.
So I'm trying to
grow as a writer.
I'm trying to grow my readers.
And I'm trying to be what you
guys, give you guys new things,
give you guys what you want from
me but also be true to myself.
So yeah. How close are we here?
Time wise?
Fifteen minutes to
go but including Q&A?
Okay. So let's do some Q&A.
How about that?
It's really hard to see.
Come on, you guys
have questions.
I know you do.
Come on. You can
ask me anything.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Okay. Who's first?
I can't see.
These lights are like
really bright in my eyes.
So you guys, let's go over
here because I saw you.
>> Okay. So in my local library,
I noticed that a few years ago
that they didn't have
your book "Tricks."
So I contacted them about
it because it's odd.
They had all of your
other books.
And it appears that
it's being challenged.
How do I counteract that?
>> Ellen Hopkins: Well,
you can, okay, so --
I don't doubt that
book's being challenged.
That book -- I mean,
as far as my books go,
as far as content goes,
that one goes as far,
if you don't know what "Tricks"
is, it deals and the sequel
"Traffick," they deal
with domestic minor
sex trafficking,
so teen prostitution.
You could start a petition.
I can give you letters--
Like if you email me,
I can send you letters
from readers about why
that book is important to
them, what it meant to them,
how it helped them through.
And for me, I wanted to explore
teen prostitution because I live
in Reno and there was an
FBI bust there, a big raid.
They came in and
they took 23 kids,
all under the age of 12, out.
And so domestic minor sex
trafficking, the average age,
the average age of a
young person trafficked
in is 12 years old.
That's the average age.
So it's important that we
understand possible victims,
like shopping mall kids who
like could be victimized easily,
what perpetrators look like.
I just had an article come
out in "VOYA Magazine"
and the big thing is libraries
are now one of the places
that the traffickers
target because they look
for vulnerable kids and a lot
of vulnerable kids
end up in libraries.
So that might be a
way of looking at it,
of approaching them as well.
In fact, if you -- I can
send you that article
and it might be interesting for
your librarian to look at it
and read it because "VOYA" is
very much involved with trying
to change that as part of that.
>> Great. Thank you.
>> Ellen Hopkins:
But that content,
it's difficult content for sure.
Also, "Traffick" which is so --
"Tricks" is about five kids --
>> They don't have that either.
>> Ellen Hopkins:
"Tricks" is about five kids
from all different parts
of the country who end
up on the streets of Las
Vegas turning tricks, right.
"Traffick" is about
what happens to them
after they're pulled out.
Can they go back.
Can they find love?
Will their parents
take them back?
So it's about -- One's
about victimization
and the other is
about survivorship.
And so there is a way
out and there is hope.
And I worked with a lot
of survivors helping them write
their own stories, draw pictures
if they couldn't write,
and so they shared a lot
of really interesting stories,
many of which are reflected
in that book, in "Traffick."
>> Okay, great.
Thank you so much.
>> Ellen Hopkins:
Okay, over there.
>> Okay, so what advice would
you give someone who people
who are close to them
are starting to go
down that same path as "Crank?"
>> Ellen Hopkins: So what's
really, really hard is
to watch a friend go
that way or a relative.
For those people, they
have to know that you care
about them a lot but that
you can't enable that.
And it's really,
really important
that you don't enable that.
So like there are family --
You can't give them money
because the money will
go there, you know.
Even if they say it's
going to rent or whatever,
to let them know that give
them a copy of a book like that
or like "Tweak" or
like, you know,
that really shows how far you
can fall if you choose that path
and it doesn't take very long.
You can tell their parents.
I mean, if you want
to get that involved,
it depends on how close
you are to their family
of if the whole family
knows anyway, I mean,
really sometimes it takes a
real intervention to be able
to save them because once
-- So like for my daughter,
she started at 16,
17 years old, right.
She is now 38 years old and so
it's been that long of a journey
for her in and out of that.
Even if you get help, it
will always call to you.
And your life, your
dreams, they go.
So talk to them about their
dreams and what they want
and then see if you can talk
to them about how taking
that route is going to
take that dream away.
For my daughter, it was her
dream was computer animation
and she was on a fast
track to a full scholarship
at the Art Institute of Seattle
and that's all gone to her now.
She can't do it anymore.
So especially that kind of
drug, I mean, it's brain damage.
There are a lot of
different things
that go wrong when
you go that way.
>> Thank you.
>> First, I would
like to say thank you
because your book has helped
me help other people in, like,
my community and my
neighborhood so first I want
to give you a thank
you, Ms. Hopkins.
Second, I would like to ask you
where you draw your inspiration
from for all these books?
Like, do they come
straight from all the things
that are happening like social
media and in like the world
or do they come from
like personal experience
or like survivor stories?
>> Ellen Hopkins: It's
a mixture of both.
So, I mean, a lot of
it is social media.
You know, I was really
early to social media.
When I started doing this,
when "Crank" came out,
the only social medial
platform out there was My Space.
That gives you an idea
how long ago it was.
Right? But I discovered very
quickly the value of being able
to connect online with
my readers, one on one,
like it's a private space.
So they would come to
me and share stories.
And I do, I have, I keep reader
letters and there are many,
many, many and some of them
are just they are devastating.
Those seem to come to
me like after midnight.
I don't know why.
It's like, because
I'm tired, you know,
too many glasses of wine.
I'm crying for these kids.
But social media is one
way and I do, I get stories
and people want to share
their stories with me.
A lot of times it is family.
It's friends.
It might be something
I see on the news.
You know, there are lots of
ways that I gather inspiration
or think about new
stories or whatever.
>> Thank you.
>> Ellen Hopkins: Yep.
>> So I've been reading
your books since like 2007
and I was lucky because my
dad bought like "Crank, Glass,
and Impulse" all at
the same time and I was
like that never happens
but so, yeah.
But the thing is, now looking on
the shelves and seeing the books
and I noticed that covers
have changed and like
to me it feels less
impactful because like "Crank"
and "Glass," you know, were like
first covers and so now I'm just
like and so like I want
to know why that happened
and how you feel about it.
>> Ellen Hopkins:
So cover design is
like not up to me at all.
That's a publisher decision.
I had the same designer for
the first several books.
And then my publisher was like,
let's update you, let's like,
you know, try to
draw new readers
in because maybe those covers
are something they've seen
for such a long time
that they've kind
of just dismissed them.
Do you know what I mean?
I mean, there are also
readers that will open it up
and see verse and that's it.
They don't -- They're not
even going to do that.
So covers, although I think,
I mean, that's a cover.
Yeah? I mean, it tells
you exactly what it is.
And you know why it's like that?
Because big book
stores, Barnes & Noble,
won't let young adult
have an actual picture
of a gun on a cover.
So book stories, did you know
book stores actually do have
input into cover design?
If they like see a cover and
they think it's not going
to like look good on
their bookshelves,
they will actually go back to
the publisher and say this needs
to change for some reason.
It's interesting.
But yeah, cover is not
up to me so much anymore.
I can veto it.
If it's something I
really hated, I could say,
yeah, I don't think so.
>> Thank you.
>> I recently had a
debate with a friend
about like the differences
between young adult
books and fiction books.
And I was wondering
if in your experience,
like how do you decide
that when you sit
down to write something that's
it's going to be intended
for children versus for adults.
>> Ellen Hopkins: So the
difference between YA and adult
that I can see is that
adult is more reflective.
It's like looking back often.
You know what I mean?
It's like -- Okay,
so I put it this way.
So young people have this
amount of experience.
Right? At 16, you
have this much.
As an adult, you know,
that starts to widen.
And by the time you
get ancient like me,
it's like I got so
much experience.
But it's a reflective thing.
So it's like looking back.
So I can judge today by
this many yesterdays.
Young people can judge today
by this many yesterdays.
So writing for young people
is more about discovery,
learning who you are, figuring
out where you want to go.
Writing for adults is
more like regret, I guess.
I really should've
gotten together
with that guy instead
of that guy.
You know what I mean?
So I think that's
the difference.
And also there's a
pacing difference.
So if you want to
write for young people,
it's a different kind of pacing.
It has to be a little faster.
The plot needs to be
less heavy, I guess.
I don't know.
There's a lot of different
things but it's really
about discovery versus
reflection.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi. So you talked about
how in your first few books,
your verse was more
simplistic and you wanted
to catch younger readers and
now you've moved into prose
and you're writing a
book almost all in prose.
Do you find the two, verse and
prose, very different to write
or do you them similar?
>> Ellen Hopkins: I actually
prefer writing in verse.
Verse is, it's every word
has count has the page.
There's a lot of -- It's
a lot more difficult
to write in verse.
I will tell you that for a
fact because you have to --
Every single word has to count.
So it's word choice.
It's deciding what can, what
one word can take the place
of like a whole sentence,
maybe, sometimes.
So I'm going to actually --
I'm going to write in verse.
I'm going to do a middle grade
novel because this one child
of ours, the one that
just started high school,
he came to us with
PTSD, like because
of early childhood trauma from
like the boyfriends and stuff.
So when he first got to us,
he would like have daily throw
himself on the floor meltdowns,
screaming into his hoodie.
So he'd go to school and
when he started school
in this new school, everybody
thought he was the freak
but nobody wanted to know why.
You know what I mean?
So I want to write a
book for kids like him,
for the classmates
of kids like him
so they can understand there's
a reason why kids might be
in that kind of space.
And I will tell you,
those things used
to happen three or
four times a day.
They don't happen at
all anymore, seriously.
I mean, and it was a slow
change, like a slow change.
And like last year,
I would say it would
like once every couple weeks.
This year, like it's done.
So they can come around.
They can change.
And they should be allowed
to change and to have friends
that accept them but I think
verse is going to be the way
to tell that story because it's,
again, such an interior story.
So verse is like, it's
like really viewing
this world, right.
Prose is like describing
the world.
This is like viewing the world.
And, you know, there are a lot
of giant successful
verse novels out now.
Jason Reynolds books, you know,
Jacqueline Woodson's books,
those great making rhymes.
Those books are like
great, great in verse books.
So I'm going to go back
to it for that book
and then we'll see
because, you know,
I do want to have a wider
audience and there are kids
like they look at verse
and they're like,
unh-uh, not for me.
Right? So I want both
because I'm hopeful
that my writing will
attract both eventually
and like the prose
lovers will go to verse
and the verse lovers
will go to prose.
And then everybody can love me.
I think -- Are we done?
>> Thank you.
>> Ellen Hopkins: Three minutes.
I got time.
>> So how or why did you
decide to make a book or series
out of your family story instead
of just keeping it private?
>> Ellen Hopkins: So why did I
choose to write "Crank" instead
of just keeping it
as a private story?
Because my daughter was the kid
that we just expected
her to be like somebody.
You know what I mean?
I mean, she has talent.
She was a straight
A plus student.
She has 150 IQ, like
brilliant kid.
And then you made
one wrong choice.
You know, she chose to go
with this guy and to get high
and her entire, all her dreams
dissolved with that one choice.
I needed to write that book --
Well, first I needed to write it
for me to figure out why.
But then I needed to write it
for teens because I wanted --
I knew if I could just turn
one kid or two kids away
from that choice, it would mean
something really special to me.
And now it's been, I'm
serious, tens of thousands
of young people that I've
gotten messages from and emails
from and, you know, and they
tweet me and they Instagram me
and whatever and that I've
been able to make that kind
of difference in somebody else's
life made it all worthwhile.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ellen Hopkins: Thank you.
Alright, well okay, so
then I guess I'm done here
because they're like -- Is there
one more question somewhere?
Yeah.
>> Hi. I just wanted to
give the kids a chance first
because I've been reading
your books since I was
in middle school and I'm
a master student now.
So you're like, whew, you're
like part of my childhood
and seeing you in the flesh
just I'm nervous and everything.
I have had a question
since I was a child,
since I started reading
your books
of how the heck do
you deal with it?
How do you deal with writing of
such difficult heavy subjects
and you as a human being, you've
been doing this for decades now,
like how do you cope with
so much pain and make it
so beautiful and easy to
understand and easy to connect
with for anyone that
reads your books?
>> Ellen Hopkins: Again, I think
it's just a matter of being able
to take some of that on myself
for so many other people,
that I actually feel
I have a relationship
with the creator and, you know,
I think I was put
here to do what I do.
And so, He gives it back.
Do you know what I mean?
So my life, I've been so blessed
in so many ways that I feel
like if I can bless
some other lives
that I'm doing what
I was put here to do.
>> I agree with that.
Thank you so much
for everything.
>> Ellen Hopkins: Thank you.
Okay, I'm wrapping it up.
I got the sign here, wrap it up.
So you guys come.
I'll sign some books for you
downstairs at 4:00 o'clock.
Catch me in the hallway
if you want.
I'm not going anywhere.
If you got other questions, I'll
be here and just thank you guys
for being with me
on this journey.
I love you [applause].